president Trump's pick for vice chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff General
John heighten is publicly denying
allegations of sexual assault from an
Army Colonel Heiden faced more than two
hours of questions from senators at his
confirmation hearing yesterday David
Martin is at the Pentagon David where
the allegations investigated they sure
wore this one this was a criminal case
in which Air Force investigators
questioned 53 witnesses examined nearly
200,000 emails and took a DNA sample
from general heighten but in the end
they could not come up with enough
evidence to bring charges against him
his accuser was a one-time close aide
Army colonel Catherine split stow sir
her emotions seemed genuine I was just
devastated as a human being you know was
scared but as she watched the Senate
Armed Services hearing from the audience
her claims were vehemently denied by
heightened these allegations are false
nothing happened
ever and by former Air Force secretary
Heather Wilson who said a criminal
investigation found no evidence to
substantiate the allegation general
heightened was falsely accused former
Air Force pilot now Republican senator
martha mcsalley
herself a victim of sexual assault said
there was evidence not yet made public
that convinced her heightened was
telling the truth to be clear this
wasn't just a jump ball not a he-said
she-said not a situation where we just
couldn't prove what allegedly happened
the full truth was revealed in this
process the truth is that general
heighten is innocent of these charges
senator Joni Ernst a veteran who says
she was raped in college did not dispute
general heightens innocence but
questioned his capability as a
commanding officer the facts have left
me with concerns regarding your judgment
leadership and fitness to serve after
the hearings but so sir said she had
once again been made the victim we saw
in there today was
a political spectacle done ant the
expense of an innocent victim the Armed
Services Committee is expected to send
heightens name to the full Senate but a
final vote is not likely until September
the current vice chairman of the Joint
Chiefs retires today so the number two
job in the military will remain vacant
for at least a month Michelle well thank
you David